saluons enfin ça va ouais ok ce qui
t'arrive
mais ils passaient outre s de toi là ça
c'est rien t'inquiète c'est pour un
nouveau format je vais expliquer
t'inquiète t'inquiète je pourrais
prévenir quand même oui alors je suis
désolé si je vous ai fait peur avoue
aussi même si tout le monde n'est pas
aussi fragile que la vraie évidemment je
vais vous romain tu peux avec des
tornados de la garde à vue d'un fragile
bonjour tu est doté d'une sensibilité
supérieure à la moyenne je te prie de
bien vouloir insulter mes excuses romain
je vais vous expliquer on me pose
beaucoup de questions dans la vraie vie
dans les commentaires par message vous
me poser beaucoup de questions dans
certains cas ça donne un dtc classique
dans d'autres on est sur une question
que tout le monde se pose mais y en a
qui sont un peu spéciales et qui mérite
un format à part ce sera souvent un
format assez court parce que des fois il
ya que deux trois trucs à expliquer mais
ça mérite quand même qu'on le fasse bon
vous voulez un petit exemple sans plus
sympa il ya quelques temps j'ai pris un
cours de danse sexy en talons quoi
c'était avec mon ami tandis de la chaîne
youtube
can you dance et à un moment il m'a fait
cette petite révélation
oui alors donc je confirme à 1 500 mais
je peux même vous dire que ça n'est pas
un cas isolé
je connais très bien au moins une autre
personne qui est exactement dans le même
cas bon en tout cas tanguy aimerait
comprendre
est-ce que je vais le laisser tomber
bien sûr que non donc c'est parti pour
cette toute première émission qui n'a
pas encore de nom d'ailleurs resté
jusqu'à la fin je vais avoir un truc et
vous demande
[Musique]
l'odeur corporelle
c'est un sacré merdier vous souvenez
peut-être qu'on en a parlé il n'y a pas
si longtemps que ça dans une vidéo donc
oui ce qu'on consomme
ça a des répercussions sur ce qu'on sent
mais on peut très bien avoir la sueur
qui sent la weed alors qu'on fume pas du
tout de weeds comme mon ami ton du
parisien alors oui bon vous vous doutez
bien il ya eu peu d'études de grande
envergure menée sur le sujet pourtant
c'est intéressant comme sujet faisait
les médias grecs mais il se trouve qu'on
ne mène pas d'études scientifiques de
grande envergure sur un sujet parce
qu'il est intéressant on emmène pour
deux raisons 1
parce que c'est un vrai problème auquel
il faut trouver une solution absolument
2 si cette solution peut ramener de
l'argent à celui qui la trouve c'est à
dire à celui qui mène l'étude
scientifique et qui peut la vendre après
aux gens là on est d'accord que ça
remplit pas les critères
mais il ya quand même des gens qui se
sont penchés sur la question et voilà ce
qu'il en ressort d'abord je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais on a deux sortes
de sueur celte est sécrétée par les
glandes et krine qui perle un petit peu
partout à la surface de notre peau qui
est composée à 99 % d'eau et de sel et
qui sert à nous rafraîchir quand il fait
trop chaud et celte est sécrétée par les
glandes apocrines qui est un cocktail un
petit peu plus élaboré donc plus odorant
qu'on largue
quand on fait un effort ou quand on
stresse et qu'on retrouve notamment au
niveau des aisselles et des organes
génitaux mais on va pas parler de ça
bref c'est celle là qui nous intéresse
il ya un chercheur du nom de matane
celle au mit qui a analysé les
différents composés chimiques du
cannabis d'un côté et de la sueur de
l'autre et il a remarqué qu'ils en
avaient plus d'une dizaine en commun
alors évidemment tout le monde les a pas
à tout le monde à une sueur différentes
et des bactéries sur la peau différente
qui elle-même mangenot tueur et rejette
des substances odorantes
évidemment tout ça ça varie en quantité
et en qualité d'une personne à l'autre
mais si votre petit cocktail personnel y
rassemble sept vies zen de composer et
ben votre sueur et son avis un autre
chercheur interrogé par vice magazine a
avancé une autre explication qui
implique les paires peine les terpènes
fait des hydrocarbures c'est à dire des
molécules composé d'hydrogène et de
carbone qui sont produites par des
plantes et qui sont particulièrement
odorantes
quand on consomme du cannabis le
chercheur avance que ses paires peine
pour être stockées dans nos graisses pan
très longtemps et finir par être évacués
par notre transpiration d'où l'odeur
oui mais alors si on fume pas et ben en
extrapolant un peu on peut imaginer que
si on consomme régulièrement différents
aliments qui ont des terpènes en commun
avec le cannabis
ça crée une espèce d'assemblage et ça
finit par sentir la weed quand on
transpire ben oui vous avez prévenu tout
ça a pas fait l'objet d'études très
poussées mais on comprend quand même un
petit peu mieux comment ça se passe
d'ailleurs pour être complet sur la
question on peut noter que l'être humain
n'est pas le seul à sentir la wii 2
enfin l'être humain certains êtres
humains il ya un animal qui a la
particularité d'expulser une substance
odorante s'en rapproche aussi beaucoup
et c'est la bouffe est qu on appelle
souvent à tort le putois
il se trouve que les terpènes du
cannabis sont assez proches des
substances qui composent le liquide
produite par les glandes anales de ce
sympathique petit animal noir et blanc
l'odeur est même tellement similaire
qu'on a donnés à une célèbre variété de
weeds le nom de skunk qui veut dire vous
faites en anglais
voilà si vous avez vous aussi des
questions moins posé bien sûr il ya un
stade twitter facebook
je vous mets tout ça dans la description
de la vidéo mais il ya aussi l'adresse
mail question dtc @ gmail point com donc
mais plus foncé
[Musique]
voilà donc oui la fin c'est maintenant
et j'ai un truc à vous demande je vous
propose de m'aider à trouver un nom à
cette émission qui n'en a pas le concept
c'est répondre à des questions bien
particulière et le format bas c'est ma
tête qui flottent janvier donc à partir
de ça faites vous plaisir
j'ai hâte de lire vos idées je sens
poindre et pour les envoyer vous savez
comment faire parce que je viens de dire
voilà donc merci ok donc dtc et c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui le répare en
faites pas votre âge et quand même dtc
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin d d'autres
mettez vous bien et surtout parti de
rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]